[Music]  your dad was traveling so much that here  that he maybe this video how's the  undoing I miss my little man I'm telling  you Nicole that kid is something special  [Music]  you're such a special kid  you're charming smart very handsome ah  [Music]  Pat said you were asking about your dad  my mom won't um laughing just as a  little storm  did you happen to know  [Music]  you should figure out how to get it  under control how long do you think you  can keep this up  the government is tracking people who  got super virus  I know a few things about Dion  the storms are drawn to yourself  where's my son ma'am we're in line  you can me you and me  [Music]  [Music]  you